Payments, or exchanges, have been around for a long time.
And digital payments, or wallet's, are becoming increasingly popular. We're
going to take this idea of a digital wallet, and give
it a twist. You're going to be designing the user interface
for a new time bank, mobile device. So what's a
time bank? Well, that's our challenge. What if people could exchange
their time, and expertise, for others' time, and expertise, all
hours being equal? We'll create a portable time bank that enables
you to exchange your hours with someone else's. In
this case, the time bank is a credit card size
touch interface, and it will fit in the wallet,
like this. So you can carry it around with you.